pierre laurent le secrétaire national du
parti communiste français est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
et dailymotion suzette bloch et perrine
tarneaud vont nous rejoindre tour à tour
le bras de fer avec angela merkel
et on aura plané un de la présidence
selon la radicalisation du front de
gauche qui appelle à manifester le 5 mai
à le 5 mai pour un grand coup de balai
votre relation politique et personnelle
également avec jean luc mélenchon le
tribun au langage cru et rue
beaucoup de thèmes abordés donc ce soit
avec vous pierre laurent d'abord l'heure
est à la confrontation le mot et est à
la mode et je parle de la confrontation
des communistes avec le gouvernement et
le chef de l'état que vous accusez de de
mener une politique d'austérité là est
ce que le mot de confrontations vont
l'accepter en le revendiquer oui c'est
une confrontation sur les choix qu'il y
a qu il y à mener pour le pays
effectivement le gouvernement persiste
et signe sur un câble d'austérité de
compétitivité conçu comme une pression
contre le coût du travail et ça nous
paraît être une mauvaise solution
d'ailleurs les chiffres du chômage qui
s'aggrave de mois en mois devra être une
alerte suffisante alors ils récusent
dîner d'austérité mais je pense qu'ils
revendaient tout à fait le soin de
rendre l'économie plus compétitive où il
en a besoin
ils récusent le terme d'austérité je
sais bien qu'on invente des mots alors
scellé une fois c'est la rigueur après
c'est le sérieux c'est le sérieux
budgétaire mais en vérité quand on
comprime toutes les dépenses publiques
que les robinets de l'investissement
sont fermés qu'on remet plus rien dans
la machine pour relancer ni dans les
salaires ni dans la recherche qui n'ont
l'investissement industriel
si ça s'appelle pas de l'austérité je
sais pas ce que c'est que l'austérité
d'un mot comment est ce que vous
qualifiez le bilan de l'an 1 françois
hollande
je dirais que c'est l'année gâcher les
français avaient
avait mis de l'espoir il souhaitait une
rupture avec les politiques de nicolas
sarkozy avec les politiques qui ont été
menées pendant dix ans à droite et c'est
de cette rupture n'est pas au rendez
vous et je crois que toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion la teste et c'est notre
opinion
les gens ne reconnaissent pas dans la
politique du gouvernement la politique
de gauche qu'ils attendaient et que
françois hollande lui même lors avait
promis quand il disait on va mener la
guerre à la finance on va renégocier le
pacte budgétaire européen il ya rien de
tout ça là à l'arrivée et le dernier
épisode de la bien l'ogc avec les
pigeons avec les pigeons hier à l'élysée
est la preuve que la direction prise par
le gouvernement et pas du tout celle
attendue par les salariés qui change
dans l'achat d'un état a tendu la main
en patron un et la ville le les pigeons
qui était reçue une nouvelle fois parce
que c'est c'est un peu des coq en pâte à
l'elysée à chaque fois qu'ils demandent
d'être reçus on déroule le tapis rouge
on leur sert les petits fours et eu à
chaque fois viennent avec une seule
revendication
ces exonérations fiscales et ils
obtiennent ils ont été deux fois à
l'elysée au moins deux 2 septembre
octobre dernier et hier encore ils
arrivent ils demandent des exonérations
fiscales ils les obtiennent
et en l'occurrence on parle pas de
petites pme on parle de gens à l'instar
de deux autres des gens qui gênent de
l'état ni on ne veut pas découragé les
méduses euros par mois qui viennent d'un
million pas d'euro par mois
pars pars ont apparemment des gens qui
sont quand même très à l'aise et et ont
leur eau on leur fait des exonérations
fiscales alors que eux les français
ressemblent tous les jours la dureté la
crise les sacrifices qu'on leur demande
parmi les nombreux artistes qui n'est
pas normal parmi les nombreuses mesures
effectivement annoncées notamment sur le
plan fiscal aux chefs d'entreprise à
l'elysée il y a
l'enseignement de l'esprit d'entreprise
à l'école 22 la sixième à la terminale
que pensez vous de cette idée d'abord ça
existe déjà
il suffit de lire les programmes les
programmes d en économie on leur apprend
davantage la libre concurrence prônée
par tous les économistes domino qu'on
leur apprend les valeurs de solidarité
de coopération dans le monde économique
donc je dis pas que pour une part ça
existe déjà mais en plus qu'est-ce qu'on
a besoin dans cette société on a besoin
de solidarité on a besoin de coopération
on a besoin de savoir comment justement
on arrête avec c'est logique de dumping
social c'est logique de mise en
concurrence systématique mais sur quoi
je crois et c'est rennes entreprendre
après l'esprit d'entreprendre portant
sur wii mais crée alors que s'il s'agit
de créer l'esprit d'entreprendre
c'est pour ça qu'on va à l'école
d'ailleurs un on va à l'école pour se
dire se doter de capacités et avoir la
liberté de choisir la liberté de choisir
et d'entre eux promet il faut que ça
aille de pair avec l'enseignement de
l'est du droit à l'égalité de la
solidarité de la fraternité égalité
fraternité matin comme ça la suggestion
de françois hollande
oui bien sûr françois hollande non telle
qu'elle a été présentée hier elle ne me
convient pas puisqu'il s'agit une fois
encore de nous dire que ce sont les
valeurs de l'entreprise telle qu'elle
est gérée aujourd'hui qui devrait
enseigner à l'école alors année gâchée
pour françois hollande il ya pas mal de
sondage qui est en fait réinvente
l'élection présidentielle si elle avait
lieu dimanche par exemple est ce que
vous vous regrettez votre vote pour
françois hollande
donc parce que non mais bon parce qu'ils
étaient à refaire
jt non j'ai coupé la cct à faire des six
jeunes écoutent la droite d'abord si
c'était à refaire
peut-être que nous serions nous le front
de gauche beaucoup plus haut que nous
l'avons été l'année dernière donc je ne
suis pas sûr que l'élection se déroulera
de la même manière avec le même oui
évidemment avec la politique qui met les
jeux avec la politique qu'il mène
aujourd'hui et qui tourne le dos à ce
que souhaitait et à ce que souhaite
toujours la majorité de ceux qui ont
voté pour lui
effectivement il chute dans les sondages
parce que les gens ne se retrouvent pas
dans cette politique là mais rien pour
lui non parce que c'est tentant mais
c'est pas oui ou non juste vous dites
est ce qu on refait les élections d'il y
a un nom voilà ça c'est une chose si
aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle élection
ça ne sera pas la même élection ça ne
sera pas les mêmes contours ça ne sera
pas les mêmes résultats toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion le montrent et donc
le front gauche peut être je le répète
beaucoup plus haut qu'il n'a été longue
et redit françois hollande ce n'est même
devant les patrons enfin vous le
critiquez quand il les reçoit à l'elysée
mais ils se démènent également pour les
fameuses mesures de sa boîte à outils
réaliser un déplacement ce mardi aux
mureaux dans les yvelines et y voit avec
ses mesures pour l'emploi
une manière de redonner l'espérance aux
français avant vous vous croyez
sérieusement que ce que ce conte en
français au genre à ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est en train de
reconstruire l'espérance c'est tout le
problème c'est que les français sentent
bien qu'on est en train de tourner le
dos à cette possibilité si on continue
dans cette voie là et ils demandent le
retour à une politique justement qui
reconstruisent l'espoir et c'est ce que
nous voulons apporter le front de gauche
met sur la table tous les jours des
solutions à cette situation nous nous
réjouissons pas la solution à situation
égale il ya une solution qui a porté par
le groupe socialiste
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale qui
dépose la fameuse noah florent scam et
annoncée par françois l'en durant sa
campagne donc obliger un groupe à
trouver un repreneur pour un site
rentable dont il veut se séparer
est-ce que ça au moins c'est une bonne
réponse pour voilà la loi déjà la loi
florange et il faudra trouver un autre
mot parce que pour florange il est trop
tard
ce qui est déjà quand même un problème
ensuite l'idée de permettre la reprise
d'incidents meilleures conditions d'un
site rentable que un grand groupe
abandonne pour des objectifs de
rentabilité
c'est une bonne idée est une idée que
nous avions soutenu maintenant le projet
de loi pour ce que j'en connais parce
qu'il est déposée aujourd'hui dont je
connais pas assez paraît très peu
contraignant en vérité puisqu'il remet
dans les mains des tribunaux de commerce
la possibilité de faire pression sur les
entreprises
on vient de voir chez fralib puisque
cette idée est née notamment chez fralib
ou à petroplus que les tribunaux de
commerce n'ont pas tellement aider les
salariés à s'en sortir
je crois qu'il ya un grand il ya un
grand manque de ce que je connais du
projet de loi mais j'en tire un peu plus
quand je leur ai regardé très en détail
c'est la question des droits des
salariés ce qui manque là dedans c'est
il faut de nouveaux droits pour les
salariés l'entreprise n'appartient pas
aux actionnaires elle appartient à ceux
qui prend aussi à ceux qui produisent
les richesses dans cette entreprise et
les salariés n'ont pas et leurs
syndicats n'ont pas assez de droits dans
les entreprises sur leur devenir de leur
outil de travail
surtout que les entreprises
sont concernés n'appartient pas
uniquement aux actionnaires ont pas bien
sûr déduction apparaître les gens qui
produisent les richesses ont tout autant
de droits sur l'avenir de cette
entreprise que les actionnaires et
parfois même beaucoup plus parce que je
parle par exemple de fralib cette
entreprise existait bien avant que
unilever ne la rachète un moment donné
donc ce n'est pas à unilever d'avoir le
droit de vie ou de mort sur cet
entrepreneur attendez donc d'avoir
exactement le texte de cette proposition
socialiste donc la confrontation avec le
gouvernement avec françois hollande on
l'entend depuis les mais cette émission
père durant la confrontation également
avec angela merkel ça aussi ça ne vous
fait pas peur ces formulations et c'est
inévitable et écouter tous ceux qui
veulent sortir des logiques d'austérité
actuellement l'europe elle ça n'est pas
à elle toute seule elle incarne un
certain nombre de forces en europe et
qui sont qui domine pour le moment les
institutions européennes équipe roumaine
très ouvertement une politique
d'austérité et qui est chez tôt ce qui
est chouette à l'entrée aujourd'hui
c'est la nature asan a dit la star était
la seule chanteuse s'est pas même un
gameiro et ne dit pas il faut faire des
économies mais ces réformes de structure
c'est une dépression comme on n'en a pas
connu depuis un demi siècle de la
dépense publique de l'investissement
public des services publics
c'est une privatisation généralisée en
grèce
il ne va plus rien rester rien de public
tout a été brûlé avant ce qui s'appelle
n'a obligé on a obligé les grecs à
vendre tout lente sans aucune modération
salariale c'est vrai que c'est pas
toujours très agréables à de salaire
minimum référence à l' explosion
explosion du nombre de contrats de mini
jobs des contrats qui sont payés parfois
un euro de l'heure des gens des gens qui
pour maintenir leurs droits au chômage
sont j'ai travaillé gratuitement
alors effectivement avec ça on dit ils
font ils sont compétitifs
oui l'allemagne fait partie des pays qui
tire vers le bas en ce moment tout le
système salarial européens et ils
l'organisent
en allemagne même et dans les pays qui
sont qui sont autour de l'allemand
la république tchèque la pologne tout ça
où beaucoup de gens travaillent à très
bas coût pour l'allemagne aujourd'hui
pour les grands groupes allemands
et bien ce système là il est en train
d'enfoncer l'europe entière
et effectivement il faut monter au
créneau contre c'est connu c'est à dire
non mais la guerre économique en europe
c'est angela merkel qui la mène pour le
moment et elle la mène contre contre ces
les propres salariés allemands et contre
tout l'été les terrains c'est
l'allemagne qui finance les pays du sud
alors absolument pas d'accord mais c'est
mais ces fentes non c'est faux c'est
faux parce que l'enfant à l'union
d'abord l'allemagne organise des
excédents commerciaux complètement
déséquilibré à l'égard de tous les pays
européens
donc l'allemagne concentrent des
richesses entre ses mains qui ne sont
qui sont produites par beaucoup d'autres
en allemagne
elle exerce cette pression économique
impermanence et quand elle prête c'est
pour renflouer le système bancaire et en
échange elles demandent des sacrifices
aux populations mais dans les dents les
soi disant plan daide qu'on a apporté
aux pays du sud
rien n'a été dans la poche des espagnols
des portugais des grecs des chypriotes
tout va dans la poche du système
bancaire européen pour défendre les
intérêts d'un système bancaire qui a
beaucoup spéculé y compris les banques
allemandes on a compris que l'amant
confrontation ne vous fait pas peur avec
angela merkel ont voté bartolone premier
ministre bon moi j'ai beaucoup mieux à
proposer qu'on peut faire on peut faire
un peu on peut faire une nouvelle
majorité avec un mélange ans d'une
feinte à gauche candidat front de gauche
mais cela n'est pas suffisant
non mais ce pays a pas qu'aujourd'hui
que moi mais je me dis pourquoi pas mais
ya pas de lui comme à gauche on est très
nombreux vents mouche avec brand
capacités mais moi beaucoup d'autres qui
sont front de gauche ce qui compte pour
moi aujourd'hui c'est que la politique
gouvernementale actuelle ne ne rassemble
plus une majorité autour d'elle les gens
qui ont fait majorité en mai dernier ne
soutiennent plus cette politique là donc
il faut que tous ceux qui ont voulu
changement en mai dernier reconstruisent
un contrat politique de changement
majoritaire
mois après le 5 mai nous organisons deux
grandes marches 5 mai avec l'offre
augmente après on va faire le 16 juin
des assises de la refondation sociale et
écologique auquel les écologies d'europe
écologie les verts des socialistes de
gauche beaucoup de personnels et ceux ci
vont venir qui vont venir à c'est à ces
assises et nous allons commencer à
rediscuter
vous avez bien vu les bases de les
trouver 60 milliards d'euros pour
désendetter la france mais absolument
mais absolument
il y a beaucoup d'argent aller chercher
dans l'évasion fiscale par exemple la
sphère cahuzac avait ouvert ce débat
aussitôt la refermer non il faut
continuer ce débat là on a une évasion
fiscale qui est chiffré entre 60 et 80
milliards d'euros il ya des coups d'un
déchargement
il y en a beaucoup d'autres ailleurs où
les socialistes qui vous déçoivent ce
soit un socialiste de droite ça mais
laissez les socialistes qui tourne le
dos à leur engagement de gauche et il y
en a aujourd'hui malheureusement quand
j'entends le gouvernement après avoir
après que la majorité sénatoriale de
gauche tout entière est votée la
mystique en riant et sociales changé de
position et effectivement ça n'est plus
une position et revenir dans un instant
après le 1er mai de la division
syndicale
ce mercredi il y aura donc ce 5 mai la
manifestation aux revendications
multiples appelé par jean luc mélenchon
qui veut donner un coup de balai il l'a
dit je crois que la formule ne plaît pas
à tous vos camarades ni à vous même mais
officiellement bien sûr tout va pour le
mieux entre le pcf et jean luc mélenchon
avant d'accueillir suzette bloch de l'
agence france-presse
revue des troupes avec alexandra colinot
7h30 à paris ce matin les tracts en main
les militants du parti communiste
mobilisent pour la manifestation de
dimanche au parti de gauche aussi on se
prépare pour défiler pour la 6ème
république
l'appel est lancé par jean luc mélenchon
malgré tout on l'a sûr il n'est pas
question de personnaliser l'initiative
n'est pas la manifestation d'une
personne donc personne a du mal à se
retrouver
vous verrez la première ligne de
manifestations dimanche il y aura ce
sera après divers il y aura pire le rang
il y aura jean luc mélenchon il y aura
d'autres personnalités
tout le monde sera donc sur la photo
encore faut-il être à la bonne place
car jean luc mélenchon tient le crachoir
médiatique le parti communiste lui
semble s'adapter aux initiatives de
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle
même quand la rhétorique fait tiquer
nous la question du coup de balai la
terminologie n'est pas la nôtre
le parti de gauche à une autre manière
de fonctionner qui est plus une manière
coup de poing qui est plus une manière
activistes entre mieux mais cela n'a
rien de péjoratif
face aux partis de gauche le pcf se
défend d'être naïf et rappelle son
assise historique et le poids de ses 140
mille adhérents
le parti reconnaît néanmoins sa
faiblesse sur le terrain je pense que le
parti de gauche qui a été quand même
très très actifs nous à nous à rebooster
d'un côté sur des sur des gestes
militants que sans doute on avait un peu
mis de côté le rassemblement se fera
donc dimanche sur le pavé aux questions
bonsoir monsieur pierre laurent alors
parlons de ce coup de balai alors
maintenant jean luc mélenchon on dit
qu'il va apporter une brosse à dents
dans la manifestation du 5 mai au cas il
sera mis en garde à vue alors que c'est
déjà un martyr à quoi joue t on à bord
sur l'espoir l'espoir du coup de balai
moi je croyais que la télévision la
formation c'est elsa py goût ça fait
déjà fait des semaines que vous êtes sûr
ça nous on a réglé ça en 24 heures il ya
eu le lendemain de cette formule une
réunion du front de gauche on a décidé
le mot d'ordre de la manif du 5 mai
c'est contre l'austérité la finance
marche citoyenne pour la 6ème république
c'est ça le mot d'ordre de la
manifestation après chacun va décliner
sa comme il l'entend avec un majeur moi
je reprendrai pas cette formule là parce
qu'elle me paraît confuse et que j'ai
pas envie de cette confusion et que j'ai
surtout envie de construire moi je veux
que la marche du 5 mai
ce soit le démarrage de la marge des
solutions parce que dans la situation
actuelle ce que veulent les françaises
que veut le pays c'est des solutions à
la crise actuelle donc héros moi j'ai
pas envie de dire seulement on va en
finir avec ce qui ce qui arrive
j'ai fait toute la campagne
présidentielle pour dire il faut chasser
sarkozy et à la place mettent des vraies
solutions et je continue ce combat là et
on voit aujourd'hui qu'à gauche on avait
raison il faut écouter ce que dit le
front de gauche est ce que disent
beaucoup d'autres gens maintenant on a
besoin d'un autre cap que le câble
gouvernemental six manches en continu
par les cours d'une année il a il a
appelé les gens à venir c'est d'aller et
vous même vous avez dit non nous on va
venir avec des pancartes contre bancaire
comprenez non mais les ponts car tu sais
pas c'est une bonne chose dans une
manifestation et en plus moi je vous le
dis je pense qu'il faut une
manifestation des solutions donc je dis
aux gens venez investissez la
manifestation c'est la vôtre dit il faut
reprendre le contrôle public des banques
il faut augmenter les salaires il faut
des services publics
voilà et on lira comme ça dans la
manifestation parce qu'il y aura des
milliers de pancartes ce que devrait
être une politique de gauche aujourd'hui
d'après il faut que la poignée
mélenchonisme été du fonds mais il faut
que vous compreniez une une chose une
bonne fois pour toutes si je puis dire
c'est c'est que le front gauche est
constitué de partis qui sont très
différents qui ne sont pas les mêmes qui
ne vont pas être qu'ils n'étaient pas
les mêmes et qu'ils ne vont pas devenir
les mêmes demain matin et ça et ça va
continuer parce que nous on veut encore
élargir le front social et pour un
exotisme ensemble parce que si tous les
matins au me demande est-ce que vous
parlez exactement comme jean luc
mélenchon avec les mêmes mots en pensant
tout pareil et ben non c'était pas comme
ça hier ça sera pas comme ça demain
matin le front gauche va vivre avec sa
diversité et il est il sera au rendez
vous
sa jeune histoire si il propose une
grande ambition de redressement national
à la france moi c'est ce que j'ai envie
qu'on met en avant un premier plan de la
marge du 5ème des assises ce que j'ai
proposé pour le séjour est encombré par
fois par jour avec mes enfants
écoute moi j'ai souhaité l'offrons
gauche a séduit n'a pas envoyé moi je
suis un simple mais un show a mis en
difficulté pendant le débat sur la
mystique sociales au sénat en appelant
les socialistes qui vaut très content en
appelant les allait poursuivre jusque
dans le dernier village comme un métier
un dossier ce débat nous avons nous
avons grâce à l'action que nous avons
menée et singulièrement le groupe des
sénateurs communistes ici présidée par
mon ami eliane assassi nous avons obtenu
que l'ensemble de la majorité
sénatoriale vote ce projet pas
exactement comme nous l'avions proposé
il ya eu des moments mais il a voté ce
projet là bas on voit bien l'attitude du
gouvernement aujourd'hui ceux qui
avaient des doutes sur le fait qu'on
avait ce jour là mais profond c'est une
brèche utile pour les salariés est utile
pour le coin gauche
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce débat sa
formation il vous l'avais dit avant
qu'il était favorable à cette amnistie
écoutez quand on a posé la question tout
début après son élection par mélenchon
la ville avait posé en étant reçus à
l'elysée et moi même il n'avait pas
écarté cette hypothèse
et maintenant après qu'un événement m'a
dit je suis d'accord non il avait en
tout cas moi y'en a pas dit il
manquerait dit qu' il était d'accord il
a dit fait cette proposition avancée la
etc on l'examinera mais qu'est ce qui
vous différencie du parti de gauche
qu'est ce qui vous différencie mélenchon
mais nous avons des histoires nous avons
des histoires différentes nous avons une
tradition moi ce que je peux dire c'est
ce que j'essaye d'être j'essaye d'être
avec le parti communiste et moins comme
secrétaire national un garant du
rassemblement moi j'ai pas envie de
cliver j'ai envie de rassembler parce
que je pense qu'il ya des millions de
gens aujourd'hui dans ce pays qui
cherche la solution à la situation
actuelle qui n'ont pas envie de cette de
cette gauche de l'échec de
que représente le gouvernement actuel et
qui ont voulu changement en mai dernier
pour sortir le pays de la situation
actuelle eh bien ces gens là aujourd'hui
il cherche comment ils vont sortir de la
situation parce que ils ne veulent pas
la politique du gouvernement actuel
ils ne veulent pas le retour de la
droite et de l'extrême droite qui se
profile si on laisse faire les choses et
bien ils veulent construire autre chose
à ce que je veux faire
est ce que vous ne craignez pas une
dérive populiste je sais pas avec ce par
les noix je constate tous les jours que
à chaque fois qu'on nous avons fait des
progrès avec le front de gauche qui a eu
des débats on est toujours sortie par le
haut de ce débat là on en est sorti par
le haut et on a été vers un nouveau
progrès eh bien je pense que une
nouvelle fois c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire la marche du 5 mai ça va
être le c'est un signal d'euros
démarrage pour les gens de gauche qui
cherche la solution est derrière ça j'ai
proposé des assises de la refondation
sociale et démocratique le 16 jours et
je sens qu'il ya des forces même des
forces qui noteront chansons plein qui
vont venir le séjour et il va réussir à
mettre autour de la table toutes ses
forces de changement donc on va à
nouveau sortir par loin ses débattements
à mon sens oui je pense aux écologistes
que j'ai rencontré la directrice
d'europe écologie les verts et ils nous
ont dit qu'ils étaient intéressés pour
participer
je sais que les légendes de ce que les
responsables socialistes à venir sont
intéressés pour participer à cette
initiative nous rencontrons en ce moment
beaucoup de responsables associatifs de
responsables syndicaux qui eux aussi
cherchent la solution et qui sont
intéressés pour 20 lauréats vont ils
ressentaient la gauche on n'a pas
l'impression que ça effectivement
l'objectif de jean les planches en qui
elle peut vous ouvrir les ressources
pour construire les forces les mais elle
existe c'est en vrille et je dors le
pays
même à l'intérieur du parti socialiste
même à la joie bien construit une partie
des partitions vous vous pensez que par
exemple aujourd'hui avec toute cette
polémique dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
sur sur l'europe engrais n'accueille pas
fait que le ps a explosé par exemple
mais je sais je sais pas s'il va
exploser moi je suis pas devin je fais
pas de la politique fiction que je
serais parti
amis ce que je sais c'est que je reçois
ici socialisme également des électeurs
socialistes qui me disent ça ne va pas
la politique gouvernementale et qui
veulent une solution à gauche etc ont
pas envie de s'enfermer ou soutient le
gouvernement où je me tais eh bien ces
gens là nous devons dialoguer avec eux
nous devons les rassemble et nous devons
les mettre ensemble nous devons
construire un nouveau un nouveau contrat
politique pour dire voilà ce que doit
être la politique du pays eh bien ça ça
demande du travail ça demande de la
détermination sa demande de la
persévérance ça se fait pas en un jour
vous mener des discussions avec la
gauche du ps
bien sûr mon mais moi je discute avec
jeu mais je discute pas seulement avec
la gauche du ps que je constate y avait
là la question c'est est ce que j'ai
fait est ce que vous allez j'en profite
pour faire de la publicité
gg j'ai rencontré à l'initiative de
l'humanité dimanche emmanuel maurel et
nous publions un entretien commun dans
les colonnes de l'humanité dimanche qui
parle ourdou et le front de gauche vous
êtes aussi une force d'attraction pour
une partie des socialistes ce que vous
appelez les socialistes de gauche oui
non mais ça ça me rappelait que tu es
mais moi je n'ai classe pas les
socialistes jean studer et c'est une
formule qui je suis pas le seul à
l'employé d'ailleurs moi mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que moi je ne cherche
pas à régler des comptes il ya des gens
qui ont fait des choix différents des
miens c'est comme si l'on obtient en se
disant que ça s'il dit il dit dans cet
entretien qu'il est qu'il est d'accord
pour répondre à notre invitation et donc
je pense que ce dialogue va s'élargir
c'est inévitable puisque on vient de le
voir à travers le débat qui a lieu au
parti socialiste sur la question
européenne
à nouveau on a enterré ce problème on a
voulu l'enterrer au moment de la
ratification du pacte budgétaire
européen françois hollande avait dit il
faut renégocier le traité il ne l'a pas
à négocier il a demandé il a lyon le
ratifient comme ça nous avons alerté une
partie d'ailleurs des socialistes des
écologistes ne l'ont pas ratifiée avec
nous et bien le débat ressurgit parce
que qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce que tout le
monde constate c'est que si on continue
comme ça en europe nous allons à la
catastrophe
et donc il faut sortir de ces lmr quoi
faire un remaniement
hysteria certes un remaniement
ministériel si on change rien à la
politique menée ça ne servira à rien du
tout donc dire un remaniement
ministériel ça ne suffit pas on voit
bien qu'il faut aller vers une nouvelle
politique un nouveau cap politique et
que ce cas pour moi d'en être un cap à
gauche
donc il faut pour être efficace si
l'alliance de venir à soi on est plutôt
plus tôt à l'offensive contre vous oui
c'est ce que je constate quand on
revient en arrière sur l'amnistié mais
il mais je le connais il a changé mais
il est en train de s'isoler
françois hollande est en train de
s'isoler dans la gauche et il faut bien
comprendre que la majorité que la
majorité des gens qui ont voulu le
changement de plus en plus vont dire
avec nous et avec d'autres il faut un
autre cap et à un moment donné nous je
crois que nous arriverons à faire c'est
inévitable c'est une gazinière à
l'événement qu'est ce qu'il ya au moins
dix allemand du chef de l état pauvre il
ya un changement de cap il inévitable
il va falloir qu'ils qu'il qu'ils
tiennent compte de ce qui va s'exprimer
dans le pays sauf à décider sauf à
décider d'emmener la d'emmener tout ses
troupes à la catastrophe est de
continuer à les écouter pour le moment
pour le moment on a des chiffres du
chômage qui continue de progresser mais
pas seulement ça qu'ils prennent une
ascension dramatique
on vient de reprendre les expulsions de
logement alors que nous nous demandons
l'interdiction de ces expulsions il faut
il faut voir ce qui se passe quand même
faut aller dans les quartiers l'autre
l'autre jour une femme de 72 ans ou
quand les huissiers sont arrivés ils ont
ouvert la porte avait été pendu derrière
la porte à vénissieux donc la misère est
en train de grandir la pauvreté les gens
qui sont exclues la précarité et tous
les matins pour le moment les signaux
qui sont donnés c'est d'encourager les
patrons dans ses stratégies de
rentabilité
si au change pas de braquet assez
rapidement comment est-ce qu'on va
redresser la situation cemex
risques pour qu'hollande change de
braquet dans l'autre sens qu' un
gouvernement d'union nationale comme en
maîtrise mais les gouvernements d'union
trice ionale l'italie sort d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale
parce qu'on nous dit là il ya ces
formidables y en a mais non mais mario
monti quand mario monti a été nommé
quand mario monti a été nommé à part mes
amis de refondation communiste
tout le monde a soutenu le gouvernement
mario monti et tout le monde a dit
formidable c'est l'union nationale
derrière mario monti résultats aux
élections quand mario monti qui n'avait
jamais été élu par personne est allé aux
élections il a fait 10 % des voix nos
forces on dire pour s'en défaire mais ça
c'est leur choix moi j'ai pas à dire aux
autres ce qu'ils doivent faire ou pas ce
qui est certain c'est que je les entends
dire de plus en plus avec moi et avec
d'autres que le câble gouvernementale
actuelle ne convient pas alors
évidemment ils sont dans une situation
compliquée aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pas envie d'en rajouter à leurs
difficultés j'ai plutôt envie de
dialoguer avec eux pour qu'on dise
ensemble voilà dans quel chemin il
faudrait maintenant orienter la
politique a manqué on a entendu
aujourd'hui tapie s'était établi aux
parisiens dire qu'il était prêt à aider
le gouvernement il sait pas françois
hollande qu'elle dans la merde c'est son
expression mais c'est la france qu'est
ce que cette offre de service et que la
france soit dans la difficulté c'est
clair mais quant aux autres de services
de bernard tapie à géométrie variable
coup sarkozy recoud hollande on sait pas
trop qui est finalement peut-être
toujours à l'arrivée ses propres
intérêts c'est pas de ce côté là et que
moi je regarderai pour essayer de
construire une solution pérenne et
durable dans l'intérêt du pays
merci sujette perrine tarneaud de public
sénat arrive maintenant avant cela va
s'interroger mais justement au blocage
du sénat où il n'y a pas de majorité de
gauche 1 contrairement aux idées reçues
la veille émane d'un capitaliste
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement on peut se poser la question
là encore par rapport à la jean luc
mélenchon excusez-nous un père leur
masque c'est de résister mais celui-ci
c'est une obsession être
pour exister face à lui que vous
combattez ainsi tous les textes
gouvernementaux jusqu'au blocage total
du sénat marie brémond mais
qu'arrive-t-il à laçage assemblée un
vent de rébellion souffle au sénat
depuis plusieurs mois les charges contre
le gouvernement se multiplient
la liste des textes auxquels ne cesse de
s'allonger ne comptez pas sur eux le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rejetée exit les
binômes hommes femmes pour les scrutins
départementaux
le bonus malus pour l'énergie repousser
et il en est de même pour la
programmation budgétaire 2012 2017
le sénat est dans une situation que l'on
avait rarement connu il est globalement
dans le soutien au président de la
république et au gouvernement
mais dans le détail il se comporte non
pas que mon chambre nos positions mais
comme le chambre d'hésitation et les
hésitations viennent de la gauche
le groupe écologiste et le groupe
communiste joue les trublions sur les
bancs de la haute assemblée visiblement
il n'est pas l'heure de rentrer dans les
rangs
le redressement le voit pas beaucoup la
justice aussi assez peu donc moi je
souhaite plutôt que nos amis communistes
comme nous les écologistes nous fassions
de d'oignons de la voix et au delà
encore dans les prochains mois pour
poser parce que c'est ça mon objectif
c'est poser pour changer la politique du
pays une situation cocasse pour la
première fois de la cinquième république
les deux assemblées sont à gauche et
pourtant à chaque texte retoqué le sénat
en sort un peu plus affaibli le poids
politique du sénat dépend de
l'importance de la discussion au sénat
et la part qui reste de cette discussion
dans le texte final
lorsque le sénat rejette un texte en
première lecture qu en deuxième lecture
et que l'assemblée nationale est
conduite à statuer tout seul à la
demande du gouvernement
il est évident que le travail du sénat
est peu présent dans le texte final de
la loi recours à l'article 44 3 et la
procédure du vote unique dernier mot à
l'assemblée au palais du luxembourg où
l'ambiance n'est pas à la fête car le
travail accompli par les sénat
dirt et leurs collaborateurs passent de
fait de plus en plus souvent à la trappe
effectivement depuis votre arrivée au
palais du luxembourg comme sénateur à
l'automne dernier tout le monde a noté
une radicalisation de votre groupe est
ce que vous la revendiquer non
radicalisation c'est un mot que je
récuse nous nous nous cherchons au
contraire à être extrêmement constructif
et dans chaque texte
nous faisons des amendements nous ont
des propositions et il existe oui mais
au sénat il existe une majorité pour
adopter les textes à gauche et pour
adopter certaines de nos propositions
comme on l'a vu avec avec l'amnistié
dans le débat dans le débat sénatorial
est il ce qui pose problème c'est qu'on
ne laisse pas assez de marge de
manoeuvre aux débats parlementaires
ce qu'on vient d'entendre dans dans
l'analyse le gouvernement a toujours le
dernier mot
et d'ailleurs il c'est un problème parce
que le gouvernement parce que quand on
démarre le débat sur la mystique qui dit
il ne faut pas l'adopter c'est le
ministre c'est le ministre qui dit il
faut revenir sur le texte sénatorial
donc c'est le gouvernement est en fait
on le sait l'elysée qui donne qui donne
le la
et quand le parlement essaye de se
distinguer par son travail
eh bien il est recadrée on n'y font pas
3 monde et c'est ce qu'on a vécu dans le
débat sur la ni le fameux texte sur
l'emploi c'est ce qu'on a vécu à
plusieurs reprises dans d'autres textes
et on voit la marge de manoeuvre
parlementaire ne cessé de se réduire et
sa main a perdu de son poids politique
dans ce débat parlementaire ça ne vous
gêne pas de scènes intéressantes en ce
moment c'est que ce qui impose ce type
de choix sont en train de perdre la
confiance des français
ce n'est pas le sénat qui perd de son
poids politique au contraire je crois
que le débat que nous avons sénat si on
voulait en tenir compte
parce que finalement la majorité telle
qu'elle est composé la majorité de
gauche au sénat est assez fidèle à la
rade majorité politique réelle du pays
celle qui a permis la victoire de
françois hollande
alors que l'assemblée nationale à cause
du mode de scrutin donne une vision
beaucoup plus d'efforts mais puisque les
socialistes qui ont fait 30 % dans le
pays ont la majorité a eu tout seul donc
au sénat nous avons besoin des verts du
front de gauche et des socialistes pour
faire une majorité si on tenait compte
de cette majorité pour adopter les
textes et bien on serait plus proche du
pays réel qu'on ne l'est aujourd'hui
c'est que la pression parlementaire tels
que vous l'exercez ici au sénat peut
faire évoluer la ligne du gouvernement
c'est ce que c'est une stratégie
possible
c'est ça ne peut pas se faire uniquement
dondon l'hémicycle même si nous nous
travaillons à cela mais nous ne sommes
pas suffisamment nombreux pour pour
obtenir ce changement de cap mais notre
devoir c'est d'alerter de d'essayer de
faire évoluer les choses et nous le
faisons parce qu'on dit qu'on veut te
contre tous les textes non il ya des
textes que nous avons voté et des textes
que nous avons fait que nous avons fait
évoluer mais je regarde avec le recul on
nous a dit beaucoup
vous refusez le texte sur la
ratification parlementaire au début
aujourd'hui le débat sur leur propre
surgit donc la question que nous posons
nous composions à l'époque n'était pas
totalement stupide et peut-être que au
gouvernement au parti socialiste on
aurait dû l'entendre dès ce moment là
pour vous parler des verts que vous avez
un pied dans la partie précédente avec
suzette bloch il y à son auteur un
rapprochement possible vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure et des alliances pour les
municipales écoutez les alliances moi je
les souhaite très large ou nicipal parce
que jusque ouvert jusqu au socialisme
parce que pourquoi parce que vous savez
au municipal c'est un scrutin à deux
tours qui doit dégager une majorité doit
dégager une majorité
ouais j'ai exclu aucune aucune hypothèse
cesser les stratégies locales mais à
l'arrivée parce que c'est une élection à
deux tours il n'y a pas un tour aux
municipales y en a deux l'objectif final
c'est de constituer des majorités de
gauche et danser majorité de gauche qui
est un poids le plus important possible
des élus communistes et du front gauche
parce que c'est utile pour les
populations
c'est ça qui nous motive un mot sur les
européennes peut-être père est votre
objectif c'est bien dépasser le parti
socialiste essaie d'être le plus haut
possible alors moi je ne sais pas
si si nous il faut qu'on soit le plus
haut possible dépasser le parti
socialiste c'est pas pour moi un
objectif reçoit ses 15 20 oui à deux
chiffres will do chine c'est un minimum
après ce qu'on vient de faire aux
présidentielles non c'est pas de
chiffres c'est maintenant c'est senna
qui lui a monté et je crois qu'avec ce
qui se dessine listes européennes bei
aura vous savez le mode de scrutin c'est
cette circonscription donc y aura sept
têtes de liste et jean-luc je pense
conduire à une de ses listes à la région
mais il a dit qu'il est qu'il voulait
faire un deuxième mandat comme député
européen dont qui conduira une des sept
listes demain c'est le 1er mai puis à
laurent avec les défilés traditionnels
des syndicats et la cgt et la cfdt qui
défileront séparément c'est la première
fois depuis sept ans est ce que vaut
leur de l'été bien sûr les l'unité
syndicale est toujours préférable cgt
oui mais moi j'ai pas mais moi j'ai pas
et cela vous me demandez un point de vue
qui n'est pas je n'ai pas à me mêler de
ce débat là mais comme disons comme
citoyens de gauche attaché au
syndicalisme je sais est attaché à
l'avancé des conquêtes pour les salariés
je crois que tous les salariés savent
qu'ils sont plus forts quand il ya
l'unité syndicale quand y'a pas l'unité
syndicale
on craignait qu'il laisse plus de place
dans l'art et au front national
écoutez ça n'a rien à voir le front
national le 1er mai n'appartient pas
surtout le 1er mai des travailleurs au
front national
c'est une opération qui a été monté en
son temps non cessible
sautant par jean marie le pen pour
essayer d'occuper ce symbole ce symbole
là mais pour moi il n'y a aucune
comparaison possible de trouver les
syndicalistes leurs vergers patron de la
cfdt fait aussi de la politique
puisqu'il dénonce les prises de position
du front de gauche de jean luc mélenchon
particulièrement contre la loi sur
l'emploi techci sécurité 1 et dénoncent
aujourd'hui on vous fait naître de faux
espoirs et en combattant 7,7 cette
réforme qui comporte des avancées pour
les salariés c'est son point de vue et
ont fait monter le front national on
vous accuse directement et écouter ce
cet accord qui est devenu un projet de
loi gouvernemental et que nous avons
débattu nous l'avons étudié deux prénoms
s'est décidé à partir du texte il
syndicat des enseignants aussi oui bien
sûr on l'a mais il faudra m'expliquer il
faudrait que les syndicalistes qu'ils
ont signés m'expliquer pourquoi les
accords de compétitivité qui étaient
jugés négatifs par tout le monde et qui
consiste à quoi donner aux patrons la
possibilité de venir devant les salariés
de leur dire je vous allez devoir
travailler plus vous allez devoir
baisser vos salaires vous allez devoir
renoncer à ce lit à ça ou à ça et je
maintiendrai votre emploi pendant deux
ans pendant deux ans la liaison non il
ya très peu de cas la cgt et sud
moi c'est fini bausch signale le
seigneur mais ils viennent d'annoncer la
fermeture de l'entreprise
donc c'est justement typiquement c'est
un exemple qu'on nous a monté en épingle
et qui quelques années après on voit que
ça ne marche pas parce que cette
compétition par le bas qui tire toujours
les salaires par le bas et qui est mené
dans toute l'europe
eh bien elle déprime au final l'activité
est une entreprise pour vivre elle n'a
pas besoin de mal payé ses salariés elle
a besoin d'avoir
d'avoir des débouchés stables de
produire des choses qui sont utiles et à
la besoin de salariés qualifiés donc la
recette du dumping social en permanence
c'est une recette qui dégradent les
perspectives pour les entreprises
puis alors deux questions d'actualité
pour terminer les cette émission claude
guéant parle de primes de cabinet non
déclaré pour justifier le paiement en
liquide de sommes importantes et dans
les enquêteurs ont trouvé lac la trace
lors de perquisitions à son domicile le
sur le financement libyenne de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
or ces primes ces fonds secrets ils ont
été supprimées par lionel jospin en 2001
donc à votre avis claude guéant moment
écoutez là encore c'est la justice qui
devra le dire si elle est si elle est
saisie de cette affaire là il ya des
choses ont dès qu on sait que des choses
au recul continu se passer on l'a vu
avec la sphère cahuzac
donc s'il faut que la justice soit
saisie dans ces affaires là mais j'ai
pas les moyens de vérifier ce qu'on sait
c'est que malheureusement il ya des
choses troubles qui existent qu'il faut
donner les mouillages et cesser l
enquête mais on a entendu les arguments
de déployer les avait entendus comme non
oui mais il ne me convainquent pas les
arguments de claude guéant mais c'est à
la justice de trancher cette affaire
pour finir sur la sphère du mur dès
qu'on le syndicat de la magistrature
françois ouvert une procédure
disciplinaire contre le journaliste qui
a fumé
ce mur est ce que c'est une bonne
décision la chaîne de télévision écouter
cc c'est vrai que c'est la manière dont
ces sorties cette affaire était très
bizarre moi j'ai pas à dire si c'est un
journaliste doit être sanctionné il ya
des règles il ya des règles il a il a
peut-être fait son travail en tout cas
s'il les a montrés à un moment donné
peut être que il ça a été avec l'accord
de sa hiérarchie ne savait d'action moi
j'étais journaliste au général c'est des
décisions qu'on prend
collectivement enfin dans les rédactions
qui de mon point de vue fonctionne
fonctionne bien mais de toute façon le
procédé n'était pas très reluisant
du sein et canal et filmer un truc comme
ça et d'en faire une affaire vous savez
parlons des sept ans je me suis moi je
suis longtemps
moi je vous ce n'est pas une révélation
jeudi longtemps promener dans l'aide
dans les rédactions puisque j'ai été
journaliste pendant 25 ans bah on va
aller filmer tous les murs qui sont dans
les rédactions
avec toutes les plaies les mauvaises
plaisanteries plus ou moins bonnes qui
sont faites sur les murs sur les bureaux
etc
puis on va les mettre au débat non ça
relève de potasse potash s'est pas
franchement c'est on a monté un débat
public qui ne le méritait pas autour de
cela on pensait pas comme certain que ce
film est une attaque contre les
mouvements syndicaux contre les
organisations syndicales la cgt
mais c'est sûr que c'est un procédé qui
utilisait contre le syndicat de la
magistrature et c'est un procès à charge
contre le syndicat de la magistrature
qui n'a pas lieu d'être
ça c'est clair de mots connus merci à
bon quart d'heure merci perrine bonsoir
à tous et à très vite
entre 1960 et 1996 la france a procédé à
210 tirs nucléaires dans le pacifique ou
en algérie en atmosphérique ou en
souterrain dans quelles conditions de
sécurité et bien aujourd'hui le voile se
lève petit à petit son cours des cours
ne correspond pas vraiment à ce que vous
avez raconté essais nucléaires
américains s'en fassent et le docu et le
débat de la semaine sur public sénat le
débat présenté par benoît duquesne
dimanche à 10h ce public sénat
c'est un château de conte de fées un
château merveilles qui se détachent dans
le bleu du ciel du département de l'oise
détour des coursives presque à lui seul
le décor d'un moyen-âge d'une
renaissance idéal
bonjour à tous nous sommes à pierrefonds
à une dizaine de kilomètres de compiègne
a guère une heure et demie de voiture au
nord de paris
c'est ici en 13 182 que le fils du roi
charles ciss louis duc d'orléans fit
construire une véritable forteresse plus
tard louis xiii qui bombardé le château
avant que richelieu qui n'aimait guère
les féodaux lui donne le coup de grâce
le château est détruit il est démantelée
en 16 117 pierrefonds brume
ce sont bien des ruines que visite à
bien plus tard napoléon iii de belles
ruines qui tape dans l'oeil de
l'empereur un véritable coup de coeur
alors il décide de redonner vie au
château et pour cela il s'adresse à
l'architecte star de l'époque
eugène viollet
bonjour isabelle de gourcuff bonjour
vous êtes administrateur du château de
pierrefonds
alors pourquoi napoléon iii j'allais
dire est tombé amoureux de ces ruines de
cette ancienne forteresse qu'il a voulu
ensuite restauré il ya plusieurs raisons
il ya d'abord je pense des raisons
pratiques
la première est que son oncle napoléon
1er avait racheté les ruines du château
lorsqu'il habitait à compiègne pourquoi
qu'il rachetait en premier les ruines du
château c'est que le village de
pierrefonds est alors très à la mode on
est en plein dans l'oeil dans le
pittoresque et ses ruines fort mais
finalement pour lui un projet ne savais
pas trop ce qu'ils voulaient en faire
mais les a rachetées au moment de son
mariage avec l'impératrice marie louise
ensuite il ya des raisons politiques
bien évidemment c'est que le prestige de
l'empereur avait besoin d'être affirmé à
travers une réalité architectural il ya
évidemment un projet de d'une part de
continuité dynastique avec son oncle et
d'autre part aussi d'affirmer sa
puissance mais dans le goût d'une
tradition alors ce chantier de
restauration a duré combien de temps le
chantier a débuté en décembre
1857 et il sera définitivement terminé
des pailles inachevé tout en restant
inachevé ce que le château n'est pas
tout à fait terminé en 1885
alors voilà il appelle de gourcuff on se
retrouve dans la la cour du château de
pierrefonds et on a véritablement
l'impression d'être au coeur d'une
symphonie architectural ici exactement
on est d'autant plus surpris lorsqu'on
vient de l'extérieur et qu'on a ce
château médiéval avec ses grosses tours
que l'on a le pont levis et qu'on arrive
dans cette cour le visiteur est tout à
fait déconcerté parce qu'ils se
retrouvent dans un décor radicalement
différent on est déjà dans un décor
renaissance
et justement c'est bien ce qu'a voulu
faire violer duc surprend le visiteur et
l'inscrit dans une démarche toute autre
par exemple cette chapelle qui se trouve
en face de nous elle ressemble
furieusement à la sainte chapelle à
paris
c'est exactement ça il a voulu reprendre
finalement des exemples des grands
exemples de l'architecturé française la
chapelle on a ici c'est effectivement
une réplique un petit peu différent
parce que c'est à 7 h et 9 de viol il
reprend la sainte chapelle de paris est
également la sainte chapelle de
versailles en fait c'est une sainte
chapelle en tout cas alors ce qui est
très amusant de regarder c'est la
statuaire avec partout des animaux
fantastiques aussi impressionnants les
uns que les autres des animaux et des
hommes dans ce portique de ce que nous
sommes ici dans le portique nous avons
une illustration extrêmement
intéressante les métiers par exemple
c'est à dire que venu car à travers
l'exemple de pierrefonds a voulu montrer
et a voulu ressusciter des métiers
artisanaux qui avait un peu disparu de
la révolution après l'abandon de la loi
sur les corporations et l'a voulu
remettre en scène ses métiers du moyen
âge se considère en lui-même
l'architecte comme le maître de maître
d'oeuvre des grands chantier des
cathédrales
alors isabelle desgraupes qf6
viollet-le-duc a évidemment travailler
ici à pierrefonds il n'a pas fait que ça
on retrouve sa patte un petit peu
partout à travers la france retour se
rappelle un personnage tout à fait
extraordinaire de l'histoire de
l'architecturé française
eugène viollet-le-duc un portrait signé
marie lebon au sommet de notre dame une
statue celle d'eugène gelé le duc ainsi
l'architecte inscrit son oeuvre et son
nom pour les siècles à venir car dès ses
premiers travaux de restauration viollet
le duc apparaît comme un artisan sûr de
lui grâce à des dizaines d' enquêtes sur
le terrain des centaines de croquis
l'architecte restaure partout en france
en 1840 son ami prosper mérimée premier
inspecteur général des monuments
historiques
récemment créée mais confie la
restauration de la basilique de vézelay
alors tout va très vite à la cité de
carcassonne des murs prennent vie
la sainte chapelle de paris retrouve sa
splendeur et à toulouse
le maître imprime sa marque à la
renaissance de la basilique saint sernin
la sculpture le dessin le mobilier ou
encore l'enseignement sont autant
d'autres cordes à l'arc de viollet le
duc
soucieux d'élever l'architecturé
l'histoire de l'art médiéval au rang de
discipline majeure il aura autant
d'élèves que de détracteurs
finalement isabelle de bourre pifs on a
l'impression que vieux détenu qui était
un sacré personnage
oui c'était un personnage très complexe
aux multiples facettes et je crois qu'on
a ici quand même une lecture de sa vraie
personnalité
alors on a
difficilement la compréhension de ce
qu'il avait véritablement en tête et ce
qu'ils pensaient restauration ou est ce
qu'il pensait reconstruction lorsqu'il a
entamé ce très vaste chantier de
pierrefonds napoléon iii passent
commande pour la restauration relever
les ruines du château de pierrefonds ses
desserts d'ailleurs la première commande
lorsque les travaux commencent en 1857
et on a un écrit une lettre de
viollet-le-duc qui disent que la
restauration du simple donjon sera très
bon effet au milieu des ruines
très vite après